[Music]
show does not contain chapters 1 through
12.
this owl does not exclaim loudly and
angrily about dropping his cabbages oh
come on you know this flower wasn't here
a moment ago sure looks badass but we
want to see this owl man bloodied and
broken at the base of this pummel tunnel
because he took out one of the hinch
owls is luke an anti-hero every time he
shoots a storm trooper is bond an
anti-hero every time he defenistrates
some random blufeldian guard is uncle
joey an anti-hero every time he insists
someone cut something out also why is
blue goblin group even running he's
clearly on your side if you were gonna
get out of there i don't think you
needed to wait to suss out rick's
anti-hero quotient
good luck i've never had a thousand
crows fly down my throat before but if i
did i highly doubt i'd be able to say
anything audible afterwards also wasting
a thousand crows when a few grains of
rice would have done the trick what
that's an urban legend okay fine then
wasting a thousand crows when a single
alka-seltzer would have done the trick
what that's an urban legend too well i
guess this is now a sin for any avian
hating society that needs two distinct
urban legends about how to make birds
explode psychos what's the point here's
two i count eight nine if you include
the sword sure you only use two of them
for your owl triss section but how is my
four-year-old nephew supposed to learn
to count correctly with this kind of
confusing phrasing guy who screamed run
decided to stay in cheer hypocrite oh uh
two crows you remember morty crows are
not capable of hovering also these morty
cameos and rick and two crows are forced
in getting out of hand we get it you
used to have this thing with your
grandson on a different show but that's
not what this show is about so let's
focus okay episode does not contain a mr
mole map paki-chan or bubrina the
unrealistic body image witch okay maybe
these humanoids have soft round skulls
that squish like fruit when they roll on
a table but that is just dumb evolution
come on puss a fur was right there
you've had a thousand adventures with
these crows in 13 episodes this may be
the last time you ever lay eyes on me i
hope that's not true morty because you
look like
shh and this is not how i want to
remember you the reason i choose not to
attend high school reunion somehow makes
its way into this episode setting aside
that this isn't even how real crows
sleep does rick strike you as the kind
of person that would be down for this
kind of cohabitation agreement while i
appreciate the hilarious live laugh love
art and the attention to the triad
details my laughter is broken by the
much more important fact that crows
contain no teeth and have no need for
items specially designed to brush them
we immensely enjoy each other's bodies
what oh no king shaming wearing clothes
under clothes for that long wait that's
it the long way to chapter 13 of rick
and two crows ends after just five
minutes who will avenge pussifer will mr
mole map ever be saved from captain
eagle eye's lair will the silver scurfer
find a way to cure his dandruff in time
ah i guess i'll have to go back to
sitting rick and morty but that means a
whole new intro to wade through i guess
i could eat the yogurt in the fridge but
what if the oats
china
[Music]
show requires watching rick and two
crows chapter 13 to understand what
happened between the end of last episode
and now and why morty now appears as a
middle-aged schlub jeez guys while the
homework that seems like it's worth oh i
don't know 21 sins sure i should be
paying attention to the family's reunion
conversation but why is the wall of
watered down sherbert color who
purposely paints their walls like this
thank god this is the last episode of
the season maybe by season six i'll
forget this atrocious hue hi i'm
citadel's new mascot andy because this
place wouldn't be home without ricks and
d mortys except rick and morty never
uses an ampersand it's always the full
word and so i believe this is actually
amper sandy who has somehow escaped the
magic kitadel home to various pins and
or tellers morty survives this working
i'm almost ready to sell out so 27 year
old morty gets closed the fit but 40
year old morty was given a shirt size
too small none of us wanted to see that
discolored and distended mid-section of
middle-aged morty but the second he
reveals he's evil we're gone show then
cuts to an overhead shot of the dinner
table that includes a jello mold dish
which is the first reveal that president
morty is evil i have a hard time
believing either rick morty would miss
this obvious clue tell me how one might
bring down the central finite curve all
right time to go morty i want to know
what he's talking about me too i'm sure
it will be a completely coherent story
point that i won't need an advanced
degree in physics a few days to rewatch
old episodes and five hours of in-depth
mining of the rick and morty fan wiki
just to understand glad that would never
happen can you give me ten more seconds
literally ten because now it would be
six nice attempt at being excellent in
tv sins rick but that took two seconds
so technically you still got eight i'm
fine with that make it two five like i
said would have been a big help for you
to tell me but i should have everything
i need from you now if you were stalling
to finish rick's brain scan then why did
you bring up anything that would make
him suspicious in the first place evil
geniuses should be called evil morons
check out season 1 episode 9 rick heads
excel see her ruining the hunt for the
true rickheads who wanted to figure this
out for themselves this is why we're
with them
this is why we're alive what the [ __ ] no
idea man you're on your own with this i
mean dadoy i'm basically inspector
gadget i would have gone with inspector
convenience but fine sending it either
way who am i to judge how the writers
decide to develop this fight but also
why the [ __ ] isn't rick pulling out his
big go-go gadget guns right now
it's a metaphor for capitalism i think
i've seen this before you created a
being that gets off on you getting hurt
and then transfers that energy back to
you to use on others so basically it's
50 shades of vibrate yum that was close
let me try that one again so basically
it's 50 shades of black panther and
white panther because together they are
gray panther damn i should have quit
when i was a head tonight i do that
thing i want to do with the curve thing
title of my text tape hopefully we can
snack some untainted fluid at the source
and get the [ __ ] out of here title of my
sex tape this lazy [ __ ] the whole
place is gonna blow no i don't trust you
morty just watched a whole slew of rick
morty's be devoured by their portals and
he chooses not to trust rick right now
rick's only consistency is his desire to
survive but now morty decides to belabor
things this two full minutes of silent
backstory is pure cinematic awesomeness
it's moody propulsive and informative
without the usual clunkiness that comes
along with having to do this much heavy
expositional lifting take a sent off for
being true artists r m i mean r and m
but also you knew when you did this that
i couldn't help but sin two full minutes
of confusing and pretentious exposition
summed up as whoa
dead wife call me two-faced if you like
but i prefer the term multi-faceted what
is this tubey thing and is it always
here would you have to drive over it to
get to the garage will it pop a tire why
is hoes casual murder in front of the
neighbors is casual i feel a lot better
having seen all that yeah so much
sympathy and emotion now that i've seen
him brutally and callously murder
thousands of other ricks because how
could rick not his wife died i am so
moved you still got a way out they never
thought of operation phoenix and me if i
can't remember back two years ago as to
what that is huh i can barely remember
the plot lines of shows i watched last
week i throw that stuff in my brain bin
and destroy it with fire now you want me
to recall it by raising it out of the
ashes and bringing it back to life like
some sort of um
fire death reversi bird even if i did
remember that episode i'd probably also
remember that mortys were never part of
the deal but i don't so i'll just send
that this morty has no nipples i'm gonna
be honest i don't have the slightest
clue about what's going on here i think
evil morty is breaking the curvy thingy
that separates the genius rix from the
dumricks by launching himself towards a
space anus fueled by the blood of rick
and morty's who try to use the operation
phoenix callback while our rick and
morty are trying to escape the resulting
gravitational pull by using a unity
metaphor drive booster as the citadel is
flooded and poisoned by portal juice and
eyepatch morty finds himself in the
quantum realm until he's needed by
vindicator's end game i guess i'll just
have to wait till the season premiere
next season which i'm absolutely sure
will clear everything up yay
i'm so confused
what yes log all kids love log
starlight mission accepted what we can
do is break his age in two places remove
the middle and graft its ends back
together that sounds really violent
jerome never questioned my commitment
again
i took my mind off the pain by reminding
myself that when i eventually did stand
up i'd be exactly two inches closer to
the stars
hey you were supposed to be my left home
how will i get out of here
in certain times like these i think it's
important for me to say my tiny little
nipples went to france four storms four
crates zero stones
zero crates
it's just as well i lied that second
seat's a toilet and i'll see you in hell
my brains are going into my feet
and love
gone forever